regie kollege du bist sehr verehrte
kollegin so schönen guten tag wir haben
uns versammelt und die situation zu
erklären die jetzt in den bass entsteht
ich werde in ein paar worten in
erinnerung rufen was dort von anfang an
das geschehen ist wie die situation
entstand war obwohl es sie im grunde das
alles ausgezeichnet gern aber dennoch
damit sie das gesamtbild haben die uns
das uns helfen wird die entsprechende
entscheidungen zu treffen also nach dem
staatsstreich in der ukraine im jahre
2014 ein teil der bevölkerung dieses
landes nicht
diesen streich nicht akzeptiert hat ich
möchte in erinnerung rufen dieser
umsturz war verfassungswidrig und blutig
denn im zuge dieser ereignisse sind
viele unschuldige menschen zu tode
gekommen das war in der tat ein
militärische umsturz keiner bestreitet
diese tatsache ein teil der bürger
wiederhole ich dieses landes haben
diesen umsturz nicht akzeptiert und das
betreffe die personen die auf der krim
wohnten und auch diejenigen sie
wohnten und wohnen zurzeit im don was
die menschen erklärten
zwei unabhängige republiken bilden die
volksrepublik von dennis und
volksrepublik von so ganz seit diesem
zeitpunkt entstand die konfrontation der
machthaber der kiew und der person die
auf diesem territorium wohnen ich möchte
darauf hinweisen dass russland von
anfang an alles unternommen hat um mit
friedlichen mitteln auf friedliche art
und weise alle entstandenen
widersprüche zu lösen dennoch die kiewer
machthaber
haben zweimal
militärische strafe ration in diesen
gebieten durchgeführt und wie man sieht
wir sind heute zeugen der verschärfung
der situation zum dritten all diese
jahre ich möchte das betonen im laufe
von all diesen jahren die menschen die
in diesen territorien wohnen wurden
praktisch
ständig geschossen
blockiert blockaden wie sie wissen die
person die
die person die in diesen territorien
runden mussten sowieso im keller
umziehen und sie wohnen den kellern
zusammen mit ihren kindern das heißt sie
werden misshandelt
im zuge der verhandlungen
entstand
ein friedlicher plane zur
regelung der situation der der komplex
der maßnahmen in minsk weil wir uns in
linz getroffen haben wie sie sich
ehrenamtlich aber der ganze verlauf der
späteren ereignisse zeigt dass die
heutige diva machthaber nicht vorhaben
diesel vereinbarungen zu treffen
monieren noch die haben mehrfach
öffentlich das auch erklärt und auch auf
der höchsten staatlichen ebene und auch
auf der ebene der
außenminister
auf der ebene des
sicherheitsrates das heißt allen klar
real in diesem bereich in diesem winter
komplex haben sie nicht vor etwas zu
unternehmen
russland hat
unternommen und bis jetzt unternimmt
bemühungen um die
all diese komplizierten momenten und
tragischen momenten im verlauf der
ereignisse zu lösen auf friedliche art
und weise aber wir haben heute das was
wir haben
unsere unser ziel das ziel unserer
heutigen beratung besteht darin den
kollegen gehör zu schenken und
festzulegen
unsere zukünftigen schritte in diesem
bereich dabei berücksichtigen wir sowohl
die
anwendung der leiter der volksrepublik
von den jetzt und volksrepublik von so
ganz kann russland mit der bitte deren
souveränität anzuerkennen und auch der
beschluss der staatsduma der russischen
föderation zum gleichen thema vision mit
dem aufruf an den an das oberhaupt des
staates das zu tun und die
unabhängigkeit unserer renitent der
volksrepublik donetsk und der
volksrepublik logan ist anzuerkennen
ich möchte zugleich betonen dass diese
fragen zweifellos sehr eng verbunden
sind
die sind zwar verschieden arbeit diese
fragen eng verbunden sind mit
mit den globalen problemen der
gewährleistung der sicherheit in der
welt überhaupt und im europäischen
kontinent in einzelnen denn die
benutzung der ukraine als ein werkzeug
bei der konfrontation gegen russland das
ist stellt für uns eine ernsthafte sehr
große gefahr und bedrohung dar deshalb
in den letzten monaten ende des letzten
jahres wir unsere zusammenarbeit in mit
uns und haut partnern in
washington und in nato zu aktivieren um
letztendlich die sicherheitsmaßnahmen zu
vereinbaren und die ruhige
entwicklung des landes unter friedlichen
umständen zu gewährleisten dass es für
uns die aufgabe nummer eins das ist
unser priorität nicht die konfrontation
sondern die sicherung der sicherheit und
der bedingung zu weiterentwickeln aber
wir müssen auch die realitäten
wahrnehmen in denen wir leben und wir
schon
wie schon mehrfach und wenn russland mit
einer solchen bedrohung konfrontiert
wird zum beispiel die aufnahme der
ukraine in die nato dann ist die
bedrohungen für unser land werden um
vielfaches steigern denn es gibt artikel
5 des nato-vertrags aus der klar ist
dass alle allianz staaten kämpfen müssen
auf seiten einer der mitglieder im falle
wenn dieses land irgendwelche
aggressionen aber
dir die ukraine besteht darauf dass das
deren territorien ist deswegen besteht
eine richtige gefahr dass die ukraine
zurückerobern wollen dieses territorium
was sie für ihr territorium halten und
sie sprechen darüber ihren deren
unterlagen in deren dokumenten deshalb
der gesamte nordatlantische blog
verpflichtet sein wird sich
einzuschalten in diese ereignisse man
sagt uns wie wir wissen gut dass manche
starken nato staaten sind dagegen dass
die ukraine mitglied der allianz wird
aber dennoch trotz der tatsache dass sie
dagegen sind im jahre 2008 in bukarest
wurde ein memorandum unterschrieben das
also für ukraine und georgien die türen
zur öffnung auf meine frage warum machen
sie dann und die die antwort heißt unter
dem druck der vereinigten staaten wenn
sie da ein schritt unter dem druck der
vereinigten staaten unternommen haben
und wo haben wir die garantie dass sie
nicht den zweiten schritt unter dem
druck der vereinigten staaten
unternehmen es gibt keine solche
garantie solche therapien gibt es
überhaupt nicht denn die vereinigten
staaten
verzichten auf alle dokumente und und
auf alle vereinbarungen die sie
unterschreiben aber dennoch wenn ich es
etwas soll doch aufs papier gebracht
werden und fixiert wurde als
internationaler völkerrechtliche
tatsache aber bis heute können wir nicht
mal das erreichen deswegen schlage ich
vor folgende arbeit ich möchte als
erster das wort allah wurf zur verfügung
stellen der eben in der bereich arbeitet
wo er versucht mit washington und
brüssel mit nato die garantie der
sicherheit zu vereinbaren und
anschließend werde ich herrn kasper mit
rené pollesch auch ich habe ihn gebeten
hier zu erscheinen da sitzt er auch dass
er auch ein bericht erstattet über seine
bewerbung der tatsache dass in diesem
verhandlungsweg geschieht bei der
umsetzung der minsker vereinbarung und
dann kommt bekommt jeder ein wort
letztendlich müssen sie entscheiden was
machen wir dann weiter und wie sollen
wir verfahren ausgehend aus der
situation lee für den heutigen tag
entsteht auf der grundlage unserer
bewertung diese situation bitte
ich habe bereits dem präsidenten vor
einer woche berichtet dass wir eine
bewertung der vorschläge zur garantie
der sicherheit
vorbereitet über die von russland
aufgestellt wurden für usa und der nato
ende dezember des letzten jahres und
ende januar haben wir die reaktion
bekommen die bewertung dieser retten
zeigt dass unser westlichen kollegen
nicht bereit sind unsere zentralen
vorschläge zu akzeptieren in bezug
darauf auf die nicht ost erweiterung der
nato diese forderung wurde abgelehnt mit
dem hinweis auf sogenannte politik der
offenen türe der allianz und der
freiheit der wahl der staaten bei der
suche nach der eigenen sicherheit
alternative zu dieser schlüssel
bestimmung wurde nicht vor sich lang
weder in der antwort von einigen staaten
noch der nato der stützpunkt der
unteilbarkeit der sicherheit auf die wir
uns verwiesen haben die vereinigten
staaten auf verschiedene weise versucht
zu umgehen und
daraus werden einzelne elemente
herausgezogen zb die weise die freiheit
tanzen und sie ignorieren alles andere
und auch die schlüssel über die eu dass
keine sowohl bei der auswahl sehr
allianz und was anderen die eigene
sicherheit nicht auf kosten der anderen
sicherheit festigen und in diesem
zusammenhang habe ich ende januar an
alle westeuropäischen kollegen
und der schweiz die entfalteten
schreiben wie ich unsere juristische
analyse der der vorschläge die von der
osze im 2009 2000 verabschiedet werden
und auch die beziehungen zwischen
russland und lich der grund akte und
auch die römer deklaration verabschiedet
wurden bei der sitzung zwischen russland
und nato
und unser zweiter priorität besteht eben
die zeit als die beziehungen zwischen
der nato ich dann im jahre 97 und wir
haben vorgeschlagen weil in diesen
dokumenten von 97 dass russland und nato
keine gegner mehr sein und es wurde der
wunsch geäußert partnerschaft des
strategischen charakters aufzubauen und
wir haben vorgeschlagen
im östlichen flügel der nato auf die auf
den zustand von
1997 zurück zu kommen dieses argument
wurde abgelehnt genauso wir unser erstes
argument und dabei wurden wir sofort
aufzurufen in den antworten der nato die
besatzung der creme aufzuhören und sie
drucken von territorium von georgien
moldau ukraine ab so zieren über die
ukraine wurde insgesamt die
unterstützung der minsker maßnahmen aber
sehr steril ohne bereitschaft die knie
zu zwingen als er von tief zu verlangen
dass sie die bestimmungen dieses
wichtige dokumente erfüllen soll und als
an verdacht unter anderem forderungen
einschließlich
die entfaltung der
waffensysteme
einzustellen haben die amerikaner gesagt
haben dass sie bereits sind die
problematik der mittel und
mittelstreckenraketen und weite strecken
abgeben zu erhöhten das geschah nachdem
die vereinigten staaten einseitig aus
diesem vertrag ausgestiegen sind und
ihre initiative weil die melodie
moniert haben wo sie erklärt haben
zumindest gegenseitiges moratorium zur
entfaltung derartiger systeme mit
entsprechenden fünf erziehungsmaßnahmen
größe führen die das was uns von nato
übergeben wurde das jetzt die arbeit zur
minderung von
kriegs risiken erhöhung der transparenz
die stehen nahezu unseren vorschlägen in
der tat die wir mehrfach sowohl den
amerikanern als auch der nato staaten
vorgelegt haben aber diese thema da sind
aus dem konzept gerissen aus dem paket
zur garantie der sicherheits und immer
hamann der die leckereien schließen der
usa geht es hier auch um die
reglementierung der flüge der
strategischer bombern und bei der
ausarbeitung der themen zur vermeidung
von zwischenfällen an der see und im
luftraum und das schließt
erneuerung kontakte zwischen militärs
schaffung der zivilen heißen draht linie
und
solche und mechanismen wie vermeidung
von gefährlichen militärischen
zwischenfälle insgesamt haben wir dann
ein dass die kollegen versuchen sie
russischen vorschlägen
auseinander zu bröseln und einzelne
zweiten ging im moment heraus sondern
die dazu beitragen würden dialog
fortzuführen und die nichte für
grundlegende interessen von nato deren
verbündeten betreffen würden nicht deren
freiheit bei der bestimmung der
konfiguration der kräfte im
in dem raum um ladung nicht betreffen
und was ist besonders wichtig ist das
was der präsident heute bestimmt der
anfang des dialogs um jeglicher
frankfurt bedingt durch unsere
vorausgehenden schritten zur
deeskalation der situation und die
ukraine ich mache
fazits erfasst können wir feststellen
dass es gibt manche fortschritte die
sind zwar nicht wesentlich aber die sind
da und die konsequenz und die
grundsätzlichkeit auf die wir uns
einheiten in dem wir unser initiative
seit dezember des letzten jahres haben
natürlich die vereinigten staaten und
deren verbündeten erschüttert und sie
gezwungen haben viele momente weiter zu
bearbeiten die sie früher abgelehnt
haben zur minderung der militärischen
spannung und kontrolle und
waffenkontrolle in diesem kontext gehen
wir davon aus dass die tätigkeit
fortgesetzt werden soll und in dem sinne
von mir dargelegten haben wir
ausführlich reagiert auf die dokumente
die aus washington und brüssel
eingegangen sind bis jetzt haben wir nur
in richtung der vereinigten staaten
reagiert in erster linie weil die nato
richtung wir als hilfs richtung
betrachten weil die nato statt natürlich
der uns schritte erste und vielleicht
ausschließlich abhängig davon bestimmen
werden welche position washington ein
nimmt übrigens in der vor kurzem
abgeschlossenen münchner sich als
referenz jeder westliche vertreter
erklärte eine absolute
absoluter eine position und die eine
position wird von den feindlichen
staaten ausgearbeitet das heißt münchner
sicherheitskonferenz als bestätigt dass
gespräche mit washington geführt werden
müssen und gerade damit beschäftigen wir
uns jetzt in dem wir die beantwortung
des amerikanischen dokumenten in diesem
dokument haben wir bekannt das
wichtigste dass unser vorschläge keine
speisekarte ist aus der man etwas für
sich aussuchen und das ist auch kein
ultimatum
diese vorschläge stützen sich auf die
offensichtlichen dinge und zwar dass die
situation in der welt sich vieles werden
kann nur komplexe sie haben
krise auch in vieler hinsicht davon
abhängt wie die beziehungen zwischen der
russischen föderation und
und dem westen von amerika angeführten
westen sich entwickeln wir deshalb in
unserem unserem antwort haben wir ad und
die ganze zeit der russischen initiative
dii sind bereit die fragen zu besprechen
ein die sich die amerikaner erinnert
haben einschließlich auch unter der
berücksichtigung unserer dem aber wir
werden das tun nur indem wir die antwort
auf die wichtigsten fragen verlangen das
ist die einstellung der ost-erweiterung
der nato und die betrachtung der
konfiguration der nato präsenz im
europäischen
kontinent in erster linie in zentral und
osteuropa unter der barista dessen was
russland und nato vereinbart haben und
natürlich unser
aufruf vor bzw keine aufruf
sonderförderung eigentlich zu erklären
wieso die oft auf der höchsten ebene
unterzeichnete versicherung dass keiner
die sich die eigene sicherheit auf
kosten der sicherheit der anderen
verstärken wird wird nicht nur ignoriert
sonne eine reihe der staaten ist nicht
bereits zu erklären was haben sie denn
nun gemeint als deren führer die
entsprechenden dokumente unterschrieben
haben und warum jetzt unabhängig davon
was sie vorhaben sie nicht bereit sind
ihre eigene verpflichtungen zu erfüllen
nach ihrem auftakt war die milch haben
wir diese dokumente nach washington
geschickt anschließend hat mich anthony
blinken angerufen ein paar tage später
der staatssekretär hat gesagt er hat
dieses dokument kennengelernt und es
bereits zu treffen und dieses dokument
zu besprechen und japan option darauf zu
äußern und vielleicht irgendwelche
zusätzliche fragen zu stellen mit ihrem
einverstanden ist ein solches treffen
geplante in dieser woche am 24
februar in genf wir werden uns leiten
lassen von den positionen die sie
bestätigt haben sie sie verteidigen im
kontakt mit ihren kollegen und die wir
natürlich auf der ebene des
außenministeriums weiter fort ich möchte
ich habe gerade mit meinen kollegen
darüber gesprochen auch mit
amerikanischen kollegen und die haben
erklärt dass sie nicht vorhaben ukraine
morgen in die nato aufzunehmen mehr noch
vielleicht wird auch gewisses monate
moratorium
vorgenommen werden aber sie sind der
meinung dass die ukraine zurzeit noch
nicht vorbereitet ist also meine
antwortete
butler dass es kein nachgeben für uns
das ist einfach die umsetzung für ihre
eigenen pläne sie sind der meinung man
muss ja etwas aufwarten und die ukraine
auf den beitritt zur nato vorzubereiten
das ist ein moratorium das ist was ist
liebe ich merke hier keine bewegung in
unsere richtung so etwas sehe ich noch
nicht aber gestern habe ich haben wir
zweimal mit dem französischen
präsidenten gesprochen bis 2 uhr nachts
heute nacht habe ich mit ihm gesprochen
er versichert dass in der amerikanischen
position irgendwelche
bewegungen stattgefunden haben wohin
bestehen diese veränderungen hat er mir
nicht ich gehe davon aus dass zuerst die
leistung notwendig ist zu verstehen
worin bestehen diese veränderung ist die
verharmlosen denn ihr kollegin jeden tag
öffentlich fast gestern erklärt habe
dass es keine bewegungen in gruol sich
fragen in bezug auf die ost erweiterung
wurde aufnahme anderen staaten ähnliche
der ukraine in die nato sie nicht haben
habe ich richtig verstanden
es gibt immer mehr publikationen in den
westlichen massenmedien werden viele
geheime dokumente veröffentlicht die
anfang der neunziger jahre
wurden mit den westlichen kollegen
sowohl mit uns als auch untereinander
obwohl es dort davon ausgeht dass der
westen absolut keine absicht hatten als
sie das auch im gespräch im patent
bestätigt hat er sich vorhaben ost
erweiterung der nato vorzunehmen und
trotzdem herr stoltenberg der jetzt der
sekretär der allianz lehnt diese
tatsache ab die aus dem britischen
archiv herausgeholt wurden und in der
zeitschrift spiegel veröffentlicht und
die bestehen dennoch auf die
unmöglichkeit der abschwächung dieser
politik die offene türe obwohl sie
mehrfach erklärt haben das ist keine so
dass politik vorhanden ist sondern es
gibt die möglichkeit die im fasching
turner vertrag vorhanden ist unter
einverständnis alle nato-mitglieder eine
mit dem anderen stadt vorschlagen sich
der allianz anzuschließen und das war
bedingung wenn sie den kriterien der
stadt entsprechen und zweitens wenn sie
mehr als sicherheit für denn nur die
nordatlantische allianz zu fügen also
dass die zweite zweite kriterium
generierte das wissen wir aber welche
neuen können uns der amerikaner oder
deren alliierten an uns weitergeben wir
gehen davon aus dass so wie sie gesagt
haben sie haben dass auch herr makronen
gesagt da muss man zuerst eine verstehen
was meinen denn um sie amerikanern und
weil unsere französische belegen diese
information an uns geben dass sie
verstehen so worüber washington mit uns
sprechen können für heute habe ich ein
telefongespräch mit mit dem
außenminister von frankreich geplant und
ich habe ihn
das aussenministerium davon frankreich
gebeten und bei der abstimmung das
gespräch habe ich gebeten dass im zuge
dieses gespräches etwas mehr klarheit
geschaffen wird darüber was amerikaner
mit uns besprechen wollen danke das ist
alles klar
ich habe ihn gebeten dass er darstellt
was
bei minsk
anteil der regelung geschehen ist
sondern wir das und dann würde ich auch
die anderen mitglieder der
sicherheitsrates ihrer meinung sagen du
darüber angefangen mit der realen
situation die zur zeit in den volks
republiken von tongas entsteht bitte